this video is sponsored by brilliant
there's a joke in physics that a cow is
at first approximation a sphere i mean
it's a three-dimensional object it has
depth width and height and it's got no
sharp edges so it's kind of accurate
but the main reason a cow is a sphere to
a physicist is because a sphere is a
really simple shape
every point on its surface is the same
distance away from its center you can
describe it with one simple equation
and while the world isn't itself simple
if we pretend it is we can learn so much
about it
that's because making approximations
about the natural world is how
physicists are able to describe it using
equations trying to describe an object
like a cow or a spaceship exactly
accounting for every last tail and ear
and docking port would result in
equations that were the length of an
entire page and would take forever to
solve or maybe even be impossible to
solve and equations that can't be solved
aren't very useful
so we look for corners to cut as a
physicist you're trained to look for
approximations asking what information
can we ignore about something that
allows us to model it while still
capturing the big picture
is it nearly symmetric can we ignore
friction or ignore air resistance things
like that
often this is inspired by magnitude
analysis estimating which effects are
small enough to not be important
compared to other effects at least the
first approximation for example in my
own specialism atmospheric science the
same equations are used to describe the
way the atmosphere flows over the
surface of the earth and how a single
droplets of water splashes on the ground
the only differences are the terms in
the equation which can be safely ignored
if you're talking about the atmosphere
friction with the ground is a tiny force
while the effect of the earth rotating
is a large one while for the water
droplet air resistance is crucial to the
behavior and the earth rotating
underneath can be safely ignored so a
physicist will strip away all details
and at least to begin with describe a
cow as a sphere by doing that we can
learn so much from our equations we can
approximately learn how heat moves
around inside the cow for example but if
we're talking about something more
fundamental like approximating a helium
atom by only considering how electrons
electrostatically interact with the
nucleus and not with each other in a
quantized way our equations can help us
approximately understand how helium
absorbs and emits light
something that informs how we study the
universe and its stars the complexity in
all these systems is obviously still
there and physicists are aware of it and
in fact a lot of science is about trying
to add increasing complexity back to
physical systems that were simplified to
make them describable in the first place
adding the tail back to the cow and
small effects like how vegetation
changes with temperature and climate
models but it's worth stressing that
without saying a cow is a sphere an
imperfect simple description we would
never have been in the position to
describe it accurately at all
both in the sense that our descriptions
need to start somewhere before you add
the complexity
but also in the sense that if physicists
insisted we only ever describe things
perfectly the most general equations of
physics would never have been developed
at all
we would never have been able to run
because we never considered simply
walking first
in a way
emitting information is the only way our
human brains are able to understand
and gain deeper information about
our world
i love physics because it captures the
essence of how something behaves often
with beautiful simplicity even if the
maths isn't simple like in the case of
general relativity describing gravity
the concepts are our best system for
understanding everything in the universe
is based on the concept of ignoring as
much as possible almost like clearing
your mind while meditating
make it as simple as possible
in order to take your understanding
beyond the simple i would never argue
that there isn't beauty to be found in
the details but to me
there's beauty in functional simplicity
and in describing a cow
as a sphere
this video hopefully looked pretty
unique as a result of two bits of
programming the image reconstruction was
done by michael fogelmann's primitive
script in go and the images were
stripped from stock footage sent to that
script and recombined into a video by a
program i wrote in python if you'd like
to get started learning this powerful
versatile language then there's nowhere
better than the introductory course on
brilliant who have kindly sponsored this
video brilliant is a service that
supports learning new concepts in maths
science and computer science by guiding
you through expertly written hands-on
courses on their website and app rather
than just giving you a wall of
information brilliant guides you step by
step through a concept with interactive
demonstrations and exercises the
subjects range from programming to
physics uncertainty to logic appropriate
for a wide range of ages and abilities
i've worked with brilliant for years now
and i just wish it could have been
around more years ago when i was
learning to program it really is that
good and crucially shares my philosophy
to education making it fun interactive
and a state where experimentation and
learning from mistakes
is key to get started for free go to
brilliant.org simon clark or click the
link in the description and the first
200 of you will get 20 off brilliant's
annual premium subscription but thanks
to brilliant for sponsoring this video
thank you for watching the video i
really hope wait hang on
thank you for watching the video i
really hope that you enjoyed it as you
could probably tell this one took quite
a lot of effort and has actually been in
the works for several months so if you
did enjoy it please do share it with
people that you think may also like it
and it really does help to like the
video on youtube and to leave a comment
below saying what you liked or what you
didn't like about it the set's not
finished yet by the way uh that's why
this looks a little different i'm in the
new office but uh
we haven't unpacked fully yet so
give me a bit of time here's some
recommended viewing next and if you're
not already please do subscribe to the
channel to be notified when i make new
videos that just leaves me to say thank
you once again for watching i hope you
took something away from this video and
i'll see you in the next one